Transcription: Melissa Anzalone
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
À une personne en particulier, j’avais
parlé à chacune des personnes ici,
dans cette salle.
Ce soir, je vais parler
de la raison d'être.
Lorsque nous regardons dans l’univers,
dans la création,
nous constatons une chose,
c’est que, chaque élément,
que ce soit dans l’univers -
nous pouvons prendre
les différentes planètes et tout ça -
respecte une place et a un rôle
à jouer dans l’univers.
On parle de ciel.
Vous savez, pour elle, lorsqu’elle vend,
lorsqu’elle accomplit,
lorsqu’elle fait une loi.
Elle est aux anges.
La grande question, c’est :
qu’es-tu appelé à faire ?
Pour clôturer, j’aimerais juste
te dire une chose.
C’est une histoire, parce que moi
je suis très illustratif.
Une fois, un stylo est
tombé dans la rivière.
Il entre, va dans un village - imaginons
qu’il n’a pas été encore colonisé,
il n’y a personne qui connaît
quoi que ce soit.
Et donc le stylo,
il arrive dans ce village-là.
Que voit-il ?
Il y a un villageois qui ramasse le stylo,
il ramasse le stylo, regarde le stylo,
essaie de l’étudier, il ne comprend pas.
Il est torse nu en fait.
Il marche, ils ont encore leurs -
comment on appelle ça ? -
je dirais pas un long slip,
mais voilà !
(Rires).
Alors il marche, il marche.
Arrivé à un niveau, il se dit : « OK. »
Il avance, il avance et à un moment,
son dos le gratte.
Il cherche à atteindre son dos
mais n’y arrive pas.
La mouche l’a piqué, mais il y arrive pas.
Il tenait toujours le stylo.
À un moment : « Ah bon! »
« Ah, c’est pour ça! »,
alors il se gratte.
Il dit : « Euréka ! J’ai trouvé ! »
Il court chez son chef de village.
« Voilà, j’ai trouvé un gratteur de dos. »
Le chef du village le prend
et dit : « Montre.
Oh, mais c’est vrai ! »
Et c’est le cas de qui ?
De beaucoup de gens ici.
Très souvent, le monde vous utilise
de la mauvaise manière.
Et, regardez,
il passera autant de temps
à gratter son dos.
Jamais le contenu du stylo ne finira.
Comme Sandrine l’a dit,
il mourra,
mais jamais son potentiel
ne sera exploité.
Alors j’aimerais te dire ce soir :
tu dois découvrir ta raison d’être.
Car en la découvrant, tu seras une
solution pour tous ceux de ta génération.
(Applaudissements)